all right we're starting a little bit
early uh in part because i see that
there's already
a lot of questions lined up for me and
there some of them are kind of deep
questions so this is the ama ask me
anything session questions don't have to
necessarily just be about philosophy
although that seems to be where people
gravitate to
um so let me start it's a very gloomy
day out there i'm just kind of looking
let me show you for a second out the uh
the window it's cloudy and overcast so
great great time to be here
doing this with all of you
so um here's an interesting set to begin
with by idol
idalektisch
how do scholars determine the correct
understanding of a philosopher's work
is it even possible to establish a
correct interpretation of a text what
makes any particular interpretation of
say aristotle any more legitimate than
all the others so
let's answer the middle question is it
even possible to establish a correct
interpretation of a text
of course um and i think that
one thing that you probably want to bear
in mind are
two different
attitudes towards correctness one is
one is going to get you in trouble in
not just philosophy but history
literature any of the social sciences
anything that
deals with human beings and
interpretation and that's the
perfectionist you know everything is
completely right and we can like say
this is this is right and this is number
one and this is number two and number
three it doesn't really work like that
um
the other would be to say
well you know there are definitely some
interpretations that are clearly wrong
like if you think that aristotle's
rhetoric is about you know hot dogs and
the many different kinds of it you
you're clearly reading the wrong text
right
and then we have better and better and
better more adequate you know more
productive more accurate uh
interpretations but we don't uh say that
one is like the absolute
perfect uh interpretation so correct
doesn't mean
perfect in that respect or even
necessarily the only
good interpretation
so how do scholars determine this i mean
part of it is pretty common sensical
they
read a text and then they read it again
and then they read it again and they
read it again and they read it again
over time you come to get to know it
very much as if you'd get to know like
an apartment or a work of music
and you can kind of tell what's
connected to what
and
this is where like you know the
difference between actual scholarship
and just sort of student uh you know
first takes or
kind of uh self-help guru takes on
things really stands out because
um a good scholarly interpretation of
say aristotle's rhetoric is going to be
the result not just of reading
aristotle's rhetoric but reading across
aristotle's corpus and perhaps also
having read some other
contemporary works on rhetoric you know
like some of i socrates stuff or plato's
earlier stuff and you know i'm thinking
quite a bit about this and then seeing
what other intelligent people have to
say about it right and those are things
that make your interpretation or your
understanding better and better and
better and your your understanding
improves over
time
and i think this kind of goes for for a
lot of matters right how do you know
that you have
played uh this prokofiev concerto right
well there's a lot of different ways to
play it some are pretty crappy and some
are pretty good
and then you kind of confer with with
other people about that and you you know
exercise your own
judgment and you try to remain honest i
mean if you if you approach a text with
a lot of axes to grind
uh ideologically or you've got some bad
history of philosophy
that you you've learned you know people
are mentioning the
school of athens painting not a history
of philosophy right um shouldn't be
relying on it for ideas about plato and
aristotle or any of the other
figures within it but if you know like
william durant's the story of philosophy
or bertrand russell's the history of
philosophy
if you're approaching it with schematic
stuff like that you're probably not
going to be as good of a reader of a a
text
and as to the last question what makes
any particular interpretation of
aristotle any more legitimate than all
the others there isn't one thing to
point to there's like a whole set of
factors just as we could say
what makes an interpretation of a
musical piece
better than other interpretations of it
is it fidelity
is it innovativeness is it you know
systematicity is that we could go on and
on and on there isn't any one
single factor that does all of the heavy
lifting in in these cases but it's worth
um thinking about
um lamps has another big metaphysical
question what are your thoughts on
relationism regarding time i've studied
physics for the last two years and i'm a
long time fan of heidegger would there
be no time without events
um it depends on what you mean by time
right uh when you know i think there's a
lot of questions that people have
where they assume that everybody means
exactly the same thing by a given term
and that interpretations are not sort of
perspective dependent
so if your understanding of time is
basically
just relations between
observable things then
time could just be
um
events and it could just be the
observable events i mean
if we're going to start bringing in
perspectives you know
like the laws of physics
there's an awful lot of assumptions
built into physics right big
metaphysical assumptions many of which
are not actually testable but are needed
in order to get off the ground
i think that
when we talk about isms we have to be
very careful
because you know i i've never really
thought of this in terms of relationism
um i you know
and when i went to look it up what i saw
is that there's like an ism on one side
and then like a co-relativism on the
other side where time and space are you
know real things that exist
independently and i don't know too many
people who actually believe that
including aristotle or augustine or
heidegger that they have like total
independent existence somewhere in the
middle right i mean
what makes for time
if you're into heidegger dozens
involvement in temporality right
which is not exactly the same thing as
time itself
um so i think you know
i'm
from what i understand of relationism
not really something that i buy when it
comes to
understanding time but i also don't
think of time as something like an
independent
plenum by itself out there either so
so rob asks um now that you're coming to
the close of the half-hour hegel series
do you think you'll ever read the
phenomenology cover to cover again yeah
probably i mean
why not you know it's uh
maybe i'll teach it someday um
it's it's a great book i mean there's
other things that i'd
rather
buy hegel i'd rather read cover to cover
again like the philosophy of write i
don't know that i'll ever read the
science of logic cover to cover again
let alone the encyclopedia logic but
some of the lectures
quite possibly and so you know
maybe i will with the phenomenology
maybe i won't i'm going to be doing some
writing and some teaching on hegel
in the coming years
i i would like to actually write a book
i've been kicking this around in my head
for a long time sort of a critical
appraisal what did hegel get right and
to what degree did he actually get it
right because i don't think that he goes
right about about everything
i think there's a lot of gaps and stuff
in in his uh treatments of things
so
yeah i'll probably you know hegel will
probably always be with me
maximum uh which interpretation of the
school of athens painting by raphael do
you find more convincing the one
regarding the metaphysics or the one
regarding eudaimonia i don't find any
convincing because i don't actually care
about any of the interpretations
of the school of athens painting
i'm not even sure what what is being
referred to in these interpretations i
mean is the metaphysics one supposed to
be like plato squaring off against
aristotle
um you know bad history of philosophy
will say stuff like oh plato was an
idealist aristotle was a realist it's
way more complicated than that
and so i wouldn't i wouldn't read too
much into that painting which is an
incredibly idealized
um
depiction of the history of ideas you
know things are always way more
complicated than that
uh roughly bumble asks a very
interesting question one i haven't
thought of which is a great question
actually
any plans to add mock shaler to your
philosophers in the midst of history
series
um i didn't have any but you know
actually that's not a bad idea i mean he
he certainly had a lot of views on
historical development i mean it's too
bad shaler died so so young
and he
he you know he contributed to
the development of some discipline
sociology of knowledge for example
um i don't know that he had a huge
impact on history itself
as a matter of fact even in continental
philosophy he's often quite overlooked
even though he's clearly
in his time a major philosopher
and i do like schaeler quite a bit
so i don't know maybe maybe i'd do him
in the 20th century portion of it you
know i'm doing maurice blondell this
year so that that's kind of cool um i
still do need to figure out who i'm
going to do for next year i mean the
medieval is easy bonaventure because i
was supposed to do it this year and then
i got coveted and i couldn't do it
but who will i do for ancient who will i
do for uh
modern and then who will i do for 19th
or 20th century
um shaler could fit in there i mean i'm
i'm kind of
i kind of like to pick people who had a
bigger historical impact but but
shaler's a cool guy so maybe i will i
don't know we'll see
um
tullius do you think john rawls is
another philosophers in the midst of
history thing would you think john rawls
would be a viable choice for a
philosopher's in the midst of history
talk also i just began tutoring athletes
at my uni for their philosophy classes
any tips for tutoring so two very
different questions
i'm not a big fan of rawls and i guess
you know he's had a big impact
in political theory but that's in part
because
analytic political theory was so
moribund
i kind of see him as the sign of
problems more than solutions i mean if
all you've got to offer are nozick and
rawls then
it's not you know it doesn't measure up
to previous centuries or or even
contemporary stuff across the atlantic
you know um so i don't know that i would
do rawls i think there's many people way
more deserving of being in the
philosophers in the midst of history
series than him
um now tutoring um
well you got to meet your students where
they are
it's tempting to get kind of
irritated with them and you got to learn
how to handle that
i by the way when i first started
tutoring i was tutoring
students from taiwan and hong kong and
mainland china in
english writing history and a few other
disciplines then i also tutored math for
american students the chinese students
did not need help with that the american
students needed a lot of help with that
and i would get frustrated with the
students quite often um and so you want
to you know you want to catch your
frustrations when they're happening
remind yourself that
the whole point of you tutoring them is
they don't understand and they're
looking to you for for help you know so
maybe if you do that that can be helpful
and athletes
you know some athletes are very very
dumb and are there in college basically
to play on the sports teams that are
kind of coddled others are very smart
and hard workers
it very much depends on where you're at
you know
so there we go
all right so i'll answer one of omids uh
questions and then we'll see if we have
time for for others can i cover
aristotle's day anima maybe down the
line i mean i've got a lot of stuff to
cover
if you want something specifically done
you can always
commission it which is different than
requesting it i get requests like every
week do this do that do this do that
if you want to pay for my time to not do
the other things that i'm already
committed to to doing or planned to
doing and get your you know your name on
the video as this was commissioned by so
and so then i'm happy to consider that
and i've done that in the past for
videos on heidegger and nietzsche but
very few people actually when it comes
down to
commissioning things actually choose to
do it
mates benitez why is there being rather
than nothing why not i mean
i don't have an answer for that one
there's there's plenty of people out
there to read who
who could tell you about that
uh sam what are your thoughts on the
recent advancements in ar ai art and
writing
so
so far i would say there is no
artificial intelligence
there is just the facsimile of
intelligence and we're not at the point
where
we really can call this anything
like intelligence or learning except in
a very attenuated uh metaphorical sense
so you know ai art stuff like wombo
it's interesting it's ultimately
i would say kind of um it's flashy but
boring you know it it could be
interesting for generating
cool stuff that humans would then do
something with but i've been very
unimpressed
with um the results of you know ai
art and
writing you know it goes way back we
were playing around with this stuff in
the er in the late 80s and early 90s
with what we're called nonsense
generators and
you know the writing gets more
sophisticated but it never really gets
beyond
those sorts of coding things so i you
know that doesn't mean that
cool stuff that we might call
intelligence won't ever happen
but i've seen nothing so far that makes
me say oh wow this is really this is
really intelligence at this point so
zeno has a great question here how do
you get over the feeling of never
reading enough of a topic well that can
arise
at any point right
how do you get over it you remind
yourself that you can't given what's
available you could never actually
read everything that's available but
that doesn't mean that pragmatically
speaking you can't read enough
so it all depends on your context if
your goal is to to go all the way back
to the the earliest questions by idle
election about
correct interpretations of somebody
if you want to like say talk about
epictetus
you obviously
need to read you know all the stuff
that's available by him which is not
that much
and then maybe see what you know other
intelligent people have to say about his
his work
or interpretations that have been
developed by people you know who who
used him later on
uh or who rejected him
but you can't read everything and so you
don't have to read everything
you just have to read enough for what
you're doing if you're writing a blog
post
uh
the stakes are kind of low or a
academic paper is an undergraduate you
know maybe you need more than uh
the blog post but you don't need all
that much if you want to
present yourself as an epictetus
you know expert or scholar or researcher
you probably need to to read a lot and
and know quite a bit about epictetus and
what other people think about him
in the present you know
so
um
massacre do you buy shastovian pluralism
i don't know that shastaff ever uses the
word pluralism so i think that might be
kind of like what you're making of it
not merely his philosophical but also
religious saint paul and muhammad had
their revelations shustaff doesn't
really take muhammad seriously or islam
seriously i would say
he is a jewish writer
he does take
scriptural texts you know from jewish
and christian scriptures
pretty seriously but he also doesn't
think that like you know saint paul
cornered the market on anything you know
um it all requires interpretation and
thinking things through and a lot of
um
religious literature can be quite deep
and paradoxical you think about the
parables you know
how do you interpret
the um
story of the prodigal son for example um
so i i don't know that there is like a
shastovian pluralism when it comes to
religion
um i would say that
a better way to describe it is that
chestoff
is very attuned to the the fact that
we can interpret things multiple ways
and historically have and that people
are often trying to impose this one
single way of understanding things
because that appeals to their
desires and
allays their fears of groundlessness and
stuff like that so
all right um
mark says uh what moral and intellectual
virtues or this is a really good one do
you think are relevant to
entrepreneurship
do you think there are any necessary
virtues for good business practice
over the long term yeah
and
i would say
that of course justice is one of them if
you're cheating people
um or depriving people of information
that they ought to have which is also
part of justice right truth fits into
that honesty we could say is also
another virtue that's connected
um
you're you're probably going to be able
to do okay in business by cheating
people by having business models that
are exploitative
but over the long haul you're not a good
businessman or business person in that
you're not you're not actually
contributing to the community you're
actually making things worse
and pretty soon you know eventually
you're going to get found out you know
courage is also needed
um not foolhardiness and and courage
that's based on like information rather
than just like animal
spirits or gut you know gut uh
feelings or something like that
um
honesty about yourself
not making too much of yourself you know
when you succeed in business
a lot of it is luck a lot of it is being
in the right place at the right time
it's not because you're a business
genius or you know because you deserve
all that success necessarily you can put
a lot of work in and that's great for
doing that
but there's no guarantee that you are
going to be successful as opposed to the
other person or vice versa um you
probably need some degree of temperance
you know keeping your appetites in check
uh so you're not um
doing things that are bad for your body
but also not doing things that are bad
for morale
you know
those are things that come to mind
right away
um
and i would say you also need you know
whatever we want to call it the stoics
have this term filiponia
industriousness literally the love of
work so you have to be diligent and
industrious
if you want to be an entrepreneur
and you probably also
you you need to be able to
connect with other people
i'm not sure what virtue we should place
this under but you need to you know
you've got customers
you
can't be a prick to them
unless your business model is like being
a prick like you know let's say you ran
the argument clinic or something like
that
um
you have suppliers you have your
employees you have other people that
you're connected with
those are all
people that you need to treat with with
a certain degree of let's call it
humaneness you know
um
taking responsibility for your
failures
that's that's an important part as well
so those are some good questions
all right um
online person i heard you say that when
you were younger you mistook nature for
building a cohesive system could you
possibly expound on that
um no i i don't think i said a cohesive
system i think you know
what i what i was looking for in
nietzsche was something like that and
that that's not actually there because
nietzsche is not a nietzsche's in some
degrees a systematic thinker like you
know if you take the texts and you
two texts in particular you know birth
of tragedy
genealogy immorals those are more
systematic but they're not systematic
right they're not they're not systematic
in the way that like kant is systematic
or hegel is systematic
or even chopin or systematic
um
and you can like look at the corollaries
between the text like beyond good and
evil there's portions of it where you're
like yeah this is basically about the
same stuff that's being discussed
in the genealogy of morals with like
herd morality and the trans valuation of
values and stuff like that but there
isn't there isn't a nietzschean system
i think there's a lot of people who want
there to be and sometimes make
one
but that's more them than it is
nietzsche as such
yasser says why do you talk about all
philosophers without including marks you
got to use the search function i've got
videos on marks
so that's kind of a non-starter and
you know it's weird that people ask
these questions without doing a simple
google search because all you'd have to
do is type in gregory sadler marks and
you would see you know series of videos
that i did almost 10 years ago on marks
so
um
got to do the work
uh buckled crane where does dualism lead
to
um
i don't know it depends on what dualism
you're talking about right there isn't a
there isn't any such thing called
dualism out there i mean this is one of
these things about isms people love
abstract isms
very often they don't correspond to
anything real
you know
you know you can say plato is an
idealist
all right well what kind of idealist
same kind of idealist as descartes same
kind as berkeley same kind as hume
not him uh uh kant
no not exactly you you got to specify um
these these very high level abstractions
are usually
not
very fruitful to work with
uh not foster have you read any iris
marion young no but that doesn't really
mean anything because
there's many many many people who i
haven't read so i wouldn't read anything
into that
andrew van orden i'm currently reading
saving persuasion by brian garston i was
wondering if you have any book
suggestions on persuasion rhetoric or
dealing with people we disagree with
yeah i mean plato's dialogues um address
rhetoric and are also
good examples of how this you know
there's not just socrates there's
although also people like the you know
uh eliatic stranger but how how do you
deal with disagreement there it's
modeled in plato's dialogues
aristotle he has a whole work the art of
rhetoric cicero has a number of works on
rhetoric
and then we can go all the way down to
the present probably the the book the
20th century theorist
who i like the most when it comes to
rhetoric its relation to philosophy
persuasion communication
is a kim perlman
uh with uh who wrote with um
olbrex tataka and probably
mispronouncing the name
um the new rhetoric
really awesome book and if you read that
book it's one of the great features
about it is he
they or they are bringing up so many
other
people
that you're going to get
introductions to all sorts of other
thinkers when it comes to rhetoric and
persuasion right
all right uh let's see
omid has some advice
uh
oh
i mean
this is the same thing as comes up every
single time why aren't you doing islamic
scholarship why why am i not doing
chinese stuff why am i not doing indian
i don't read arabic i don't read
classical chinese i don't read poly or
sanskrit
the world is vast there are many
different people doing work i don't need
to be doing it you know work on islamic
philosophy because there's plenty of
other people out there to do it i'm not
a you know
jack of all trades i stick to the areas
that i'm competent in and the things
that i'm really interested in
and have the time for so
um
this probably comes up every other ama
why aren't you doing this well because i
don't have to
it's enough i mean it would be enough if
i just did aristotle well and didn't
even do descartes and didn't even do
hegel
the fact that i you know
i've got videos on probably over a
hundred different thinkers
um that probably gets me off the hook i
don't i don't have to do sufi's you know
somebody else can do that
uh bon tu boy how does one remain
hopeful in this absurd world that
depends on what you mean by hopeful
if you mean sort of irrational pie in
the sky hope probably you shouldn't
because that's going to lead you astray
somebody who you know complains about
hope but actually is a very hopeful
philosopher in an absurd world
albert camus you know maybe look at his
example
um
a lot of it is is
what you choose for your framing of
things rather than just accepting what
your immediate feelings and emotions
tell you or what society is telling you
um
you know so i would say that's that's
part of it and then another part is um
forming connections with other human
beings and maybe with the
the outside world when people say touch
grass
there's something to that you know
uh it's it's good to be in nature
and nature could just be like walking
along uh a path in a local park or
getting outside
uh in your your neighborhood or
something like that or seeing animals at
the zoo you know
um
joseph messing what does blondel mean in
locks you know 1893 when he says the
proofs for the existence of god do not
lead to being
um basically blondel thinks that a lot
of apologetics is sort of badly
conceived
and it requires having something more
than just intellectual
premises and conclusions and arguments
um and and the stuff that he's saying is
pretty relevant now as it was back then
[Music]
the you know the proofs for god's
existence or the arguments for god's
existence
by themselves do not automatically lead
to you realizing that that god
exists or has being
or your relation to god or something
like that you got to add more to the
story and that's basically i mean
laxation is a very complex
dialectical work that's what you see him
doing right building up something
like that
tom vincent where does universal's
versus nominalism stand today i mean
again these isms right it depends on who
you ask
um there are nominalists out there it's
kind of tough to be a totally consistent
nominalist because then you can't even
really explain what nominalism itself is
or how tokens work or stuff like that um
[Music]
it depends on what you you understand
universals to be
i mean if you if if you're like well i
buy plato so therefore there's an
intelligible world of forms out there
probably not much of a viable
way of looking at things in the present
although there's some great philosophers
who've certainly
reincorporated stuff like that into
their work right
um so there isn't a simple answer to
that right
um
let's see what else we have here
eskel would you call yourself a
determinist
if by determinist you mean somebody who
thinks that there's only determinism
then no
if by determinist you mean somebody who
thinks that there is causal determinism
but that there's some loosey-gooseyness
in it and that it includes human free
volitions
uh
thoughts things like that the capacity
to determine oneself like cistero thanks
and augustine thanks and and some things
then sure but that means that i'm a
compatibilist not a determinist right
um
jacob do you still have the hegel
constructive writing contest if so can
submissions still be emailed in i don't
have a clue what you're asking about
um i didn't put together a hegel
constructive writing contest i think you
might be confusing me with
somebody else
uh since that does not ring a bell to me
so
um
miroslav has another hegel question is
the philosophical propaductic a good
starting point for reading hegel
can't hurt or you know reading reason in
history
i
every time somebody asked me where to
start with hegel i say there's two sets
of lectures that i suggest starting with
but you know it's not as if this is like
the only way to do it lectures on the
history of philosophy because then you
get to see hegel's own take about um you
know
everybody from the pre-socratics on
onward
and what he thinks is going on in their
works and what he thinks is valuable
and then the lectures on the
philosophy of history
where you get to see i mean there's a
very important theme for hegel
historical development of human
consciousness now he does say a lot of
dumb boneheaded things in there like
africa has no history or you know
all the
asians are basically under tyranny and
then you know you look at that and
you're like well hegel's wrong about
that you know
people do say stupid things
um
aristotle says all sorts of stupid
things about women
you know um
we just kind of like you know let those
slide and and uh say well that's not
where i have to put my my focus you know
um
[Music]
jason loves my motley crue shirt thanks
yeah this is a somebody bought me this a
while back i mean this is the shout at
the devil the motley crew that was
actually good
um i think they kind of went to crap
after that album
and i have seen them in concert you know
um before they uh
split up for
what should have been the last time
since they all like entered into a
contract to remain split up they're back
together now of course along with def
leppard poison and joan jett touring
around
and so if you're into like hair metal
you know you might want to check that
out
[Music]
rodrigo opinion on alan watts very much
overrated
when somebody starts talking to me about
alan watts i just kind of tune them out
i you know i got into watts like a lot
of people do back when i was a teenager
and you know read his stuff and we
didn't have youtube videos at the time
obviously but i don't think i would have
cared very much more and you kind of
outgrow him you know
i would say similar to like other
people discovering you know
mystic philosophy
with watts it's buddhism with merton
it's you know
uh the you know the monastic literature
and also some some stuff from the east
as well
um
i just don't i don't find him that
interesting i i guess for a lot of
people he's kind of a good gateway into
studying stuff
and that's cool but
you shouldn't stick around in a gateway
you know or if we want to use another
metaphor
if if somebody's a ladder
then you know once you've climbed up you
don't need to like hang around the
ladder all the time right
so
all right kyler thoughts on raymond
goyce i don't really have any
laps says do you think plants have
something like purposes
not high order future goals of course
but is there something above and beyond
sheer mechanism governing their behavior
um yeah i mean i think plants you know
they're organic
things i would say even like fungi
and we could say that maybe even
one celled organisms like bacteria
aren't just
stimulus response machines
or if they are then stimulus response
machines are more complicated than we we
take them for being
um but yeah they don't have like high or
they don't have consciousness right um
and uh
it's interesting because you know if you
think about all these other beings that
exist we can form relationships to them
and a lot of it is projective on our
part we're like oh that plant looks sad
you know and droopy because it doesn't
have water
my my wife actually has a basil plant
that she never got potted
and it kind of outgrew its root
structure and it's all faded and brown
now and we're like oh that poor plant
you know we didn't do right by it right
but it it that's not really the case uh
whereas you know if we're talking about
a higher order being like an animal
you know i can do right by my cat or not
um
all right uh
luke macri the other day i came across
an interesting article comparing hegel's
dialectic to joseph campbell's hero's
journey do you think there's something
to that no i don't think that there's
something to that
i think that joseph campbell is uh
pretty superficial stuff
the hero's journey
uh is not universal it's kind of silly
in many respects
um
i mean you can compare anything to
anything
but comparing just what goes on in
hegel's phenomenology leave aside all
the lectures
and you know philosophy of write and all
these other things just what's going on
in the phenomenology is
far more interesting and complex than
the hero's journey
which is just a schema for like you know
talking about
a few kinds of things that we can then
shoehorn into them
but you know like i said anybody can
compare anything to anything
the real trick is when you ask people
who know about the stuff is this really
like this or is this just a superficial
resemblance and here it's a superficial
resemblance there's some sort of
development we may as well take aj
gramas's
version of you know the narrative which
is kind of like the hero's journey
and compare that to campbell's hero's
journey it's a lot closer that the
development of consciousness is
so
all right um useless projects what drove
you to create reason i owe
um like a lot of things in my life
not well laid plans
originally i created a business so that
i could when i was giving talks and like
traveling to give talks
i could count those as business expenses
for tax purposes
and then it just became like an umbrella
to put things under like my tutorial
services or
business ethics consulting or
philosophical counseling and and so then
it turned into a business but it was
never
it was never like a grand plan or
anything like that and and you can tell
i don't do an awful lot of marketing
the website is way out of date
and yet i have people coming to me as as
clients so i'm kind of fortunate
um
not sure how to pronounce this name
might be
anton
what do you think about concepts of
modern russian philosopher alexander
dugan
dugan's you know i haven't read his
works i've only read glosses on him
he doesn't see seem to me to be saying
anything particularly interesting or new
um he's just another traditionalist
who's you know a chauvinist for one
nationality and has got some interesting
but probably completely false theories
about how history works and
stuff like that i mean
it's um
it's unfortunate that he had putin's ear
for a long time because
that has not been uh helpful you could
say
but
you know
you're gonna have somebody getting
somebody's here
um i probably should read him
you know just like you'd read um
i mean think about it you know you read
hitler's mind conf right
and it's it's not just racist drivel but
it's definitely not the work of a
first-rate mind um and there's all these
presuppositions built into it that are
pretty questionable
and i would say that's that's probably
going to be the case with dugan
um
rt whitby do you think that when plato
died he fully understood the theory of
the forms is a full understanding of the
theory of forms even possible
i don't really i don't really know what
you mean by a full
understanding
i mean he doesn't plato doesn't have a
theory of the forms that's something
that we attribute to him he doesn't
actually talk about that
[Music]
it's kind of funny that we use the word
theory because theorem means to
contemplate right and plato does talk
about contemplation of the forms
um i don't think that plato is ever like
i don't think that what we call the
forms
was ever like totally clear and cohesive
because you see that platonists
have to try to make sense of this after
him
and they come up with different ways of
of doing it
of course it gets attacked by the
aristotelians
um
stoics bring it up seneca actually talks
about platonic forms but existing in the
mind of god
which prefigures what what christian
thinkers
at least platonus made of them
and we don't really know i mean what
we've got of plato are some dialogues
some testimonies
and a few letters some of which may be
spurious some of which may not
so
i don't know that we have a complete
theory of the forms a reconstruction of
what plato himself believed you know
ellen desil do you have a favorite
existentialist film i do not because i
don't really think of films as
existentialist or non-existentialist
um
dick mara appreciate your videos could
you give a description of hyperstation
not sure what that's that's referring to
so no
uh blueberry have you seen the ester i
haven't seen the ester i'm not even sure
what the ester is
i'd probably have to look that up
um
diogenes the cynic how does epictetus
match up to other stoic thinkers for you
i'd be presumptuous enough to imagine
you prefer seneca epictetus is my
favorite of the stoics
seneca has
we have more writings by seneca than we
do any other stoic
um and i don't dislike seneca because of
his willingness to like say hey
you know the epicureans have some things
to offer um
[Music]
but i i just prefer epictetus i i like
him better i it's interesting too
because epictetus is often viewed as
like the more orthodox stoic but
he is doing some stuff that is really
making him an outlier
and showing that he is willing to take
concepts that are not
treated that way in stoicism
and build on them like the concept of
pro-erasis you know
which we translate sometimes as will or
faculty of choice or moral purpose
that's an aristotelian term
and the only other thinker
prior to epictetus who gave as much
scope to proirasis as epictetus does
epictetus goes beyond that
is aristotle i mean you could say that
alexander of aphrodisias who is an
aristotelian he also
makes a lot out of prior racist but even
he doesn't go as far as epictetus does
the um in our power not in our power
um not as if uh cicero and seneca
haven't talked about that
but that is a term that goes all the way
back to
guess who
aristotle
uh epimin
very important thing in aristotelian
ethics also very important in
epictetus ethics so i think that
epictetus is actually
a much more innovative thinker than
people
give him
credit for so
uh mark smith if you were to provide an
existentialist reading of a heavy metal
album which philosopher would you turn
to which album and why
so i mean existentialism there's a lot
of different themes to it
that are that are really central
um
some of which are like taking your your
starting point from everyday life and
our experiences
um
viewing the emotions as not just
responses that we have but also
revelatory of being
um being against um
you know systematization
and uh the need to live an authentic
existence
i don't know that i would pick a whole
album i'd probably pick songs like one
of the songs that has a refrain that i
particularly like which i think could be
steered in an existentialist way
is um
megadeth's piece sells but who's buying
if there's a new way i'll be the first
in line but it better work this time
right
that represents a certain attitude
that could be said to to jibe with
certain existentialists i'm not against
you know
having um
policies and politics and stuff like
that but i want to see things actually
live up to what we say about them that
that could be you know one of those
um
let's see here
cinder says what do you think is the
best way of talking about the existence
of god i don't think there's a best way
i don't find standard apologetics as
appealing anymore well you're probably
you've grown out of
standard apologetics are pretty
cookie-cutter stuff you know and the
people who are really fascinated with
that are people who live in a world of
abstractions
um i i think that when it comes to you
know thinking about god
you don't want to put all of the weight
on one particular um
matter right
people don't convert generally because
they read anselm's uh unum argumentum
which is not an ontological argument in
the same way that descartes
presents his or the way that kant
criticizes ontological arguments it's
much more
deep and complex
but i don't think a lot of people
convert because they
they run into an apologist who's like
have you ever considered the nature of
the universe and the design that we find
within it you know i mean
i i don't think that's what really does
it for a lot of people it has to be like
seeing the example of people who love
god
and it changes their life and you know
it makes you willing to take seriously
that there could be something behind
this stuff you know
i think that plays a role seeing that
that intelligent authors who you respect
take these kinds of things seriously
even if you're not that that plays a
role as well
um
antonio says could you please explain
how philosophy can be accepted by the
young generation generation z who don't
like deep thought or something like that
how the hell do you know that generation
z doesn't like deep thought i mean
that's a pretty sweeping generalization
to make about them
who do you think are in my philosophy
classes at marquette and milwaukee
institute of art and design right now
it's generation z you know they signed
up for those classes right they uh show
up they talk about it i i would just
reject the premise that generation z
is um
you know not into deep thought i would
say
some some are some aren't sometimes
that's a factor of age i mean you could
have said the same thing about the
millennials the same thing was said
about my generation generation x the
same thing was said about the boomers
um it's it's not quite so
straightforward as each generation has
its own
shtick you know like that
so and then jack says that he's
thoroughly offended as a generation z
person rodrigo do you use memory palaces
i don't even use a memory palace let
alone memory palaces
uh
plural um that's not how i i remember
things
um i remember that became a big thing
when sherlock that sherlock story or tv
show
from the bbc had him constructing memory
palaces
probably became kind of a fad then
jack fleck who are your favorite hegel
scholars that's not the sort of thing i
have favorites about you know i'm very
pragmatic when it comes to that sort of
stuff i don't even have like favorite
epictetus scholars
um
see what would be a current example of
what frederick jameson called pastiche
also ever read robert heinlein did a
whole talk on robert heinlein again you
know
always good to use google
google sadler heinlein and the talk
would come up
i mean i think i first read robert
heinlein when i was in
middle school
and then i've continued reading him
since
um
i mean pastiche is just kind of putting
things together right i mean you could
you could find all sorts of examples of
it you know
looking at our windowsill could be a
pastiche right or you know the fact that
we have different kinds of decor
together
you know
there's nothing really
um
nothing really deep about pastiche right
kali what is your strongest argument
against solipsism i don't make arguments
against solipsism i mean the best
response to that would be who's asking
right because if solipsism the belief
that only one
self exists were true then either i'm a
figment of your imagination or you're a
figment of my imagination or both of us
of somebody else's mind
solipsism isn't something really to take
seriously i would say
um
fetty freak would you ever consider
covering adorno in relation to hegel and
heidegger probably not i mean i've got
so many other people to cover
adorno is very
difficult to work on because he's a deep
and so you know
he's not systematic but he's also not
not systematic
and there's so many different things
floating around you know when i was in
graduate school i realized that if
you're going to read adorno in the
original you basically need
to have about five different languages
under your belt uh
french english german journeys writing
in german for the most part
latin and greek probably wouldn't hurt
to know some italian because like when
you read minimum morale they're all just
kind of thrown in there together
so i don't you know probably not um
there's better people who work on adorno
who could do
do stuff you know we don't all have to
do the same stuff
uh shrey how do you see surrealism as a
critic
i don't i'm not a critic
and uh i don't really i mean
surrealistic stuff was kind of cool back
you know and undergrad oh
look at you know dolly's clock melting
you know and then after a while you're
like yeah i've seen enough of that kind
of crap it's not really that interesting
uh augustus hercules thoughts on
nietzsche whenever you say thoughts on
there isn't really much to say i need
more specifics than that um obviously
i've done a lot of videos on nietzsche i
think he's an important thinker you know
but you gotta you gotta explain what
you're looking for
rodrigo do you always use a pen when you
think or study i rarely use a pen when i
think or study because i'm not a big
underliner or notetaker
sometimes i chew on pens
but
i don't always use a pen uh sometimes
studying is just me
uh laying in the bath you know and
holding a book in front of me and
reading the book you know
uh zeref what do you think is the best
way to practice writing for philosophy
again there is no best way there's
there's ways that work for you or work
for other people
there is no one single
best way to do things
uh earl pipes speaking of modern russian
philosopher types you've ever heard of
dimitri gal
golovsky is a very interesting character
i'm sure there's lots
of interesting characters i've never
heard of them
silent mandible what are some tips for
somebody trying to read more well okay
so that that i can actually
give you some some stuff if you want to
read more
the things that's probably standing in
the way of you reading more
is you doing other [ __ ]
so
you need to look at your 24 hours that
you have in the day
and don't sleep less because you
probably you know are not getting enough
sleep if you're like most people
as a matter of fact
if you want to read more getting your
your eight hours of sleep might actually
be conducive to that
um
and then you know start looking at where
you're pissing away time you know
in ways that are incompatible with
reading like i used to like smoking uh
tobacco
and i did not find that incompatible
with reading as a matter of fact i loved
sitting around with a cigarette and
coffee you know
back when you could actually smoke
inside or you know at outside pubs
and reading a book you know
but
if there's loud music on and that's
preventing you from reading well then
you probably have to go somewhere else
right
um
and you know you think about how much
time you waste
watching
tv right streaming stuff
binge watching um that could be taking
away from your reading time how much
time you're spending on social media
um
how much time you're taking with other
matters and you can also think about
like
uh
do you need to read with your eyeballs
on an actual book you know like like
opening it up and reading it like that
or can can you productively read
by listening to things if you can read
by listening to things then you could
read while you're
on your commute or at the gym or taking
a walk or stuff like that right
so those are all ways to get more
reading in there
and then you do need to
try to think about the kinds of things
you're reading
you can't just read adorno or hegel or
heidegger all the time
you'll get burnt out
you got to have some pleasure reading
too i mean like i do that with uh
speculative fiction stuff like you know
here's dan simmons hyperion that i'll be
talking about in a couple
months down the line right
um that's that's still reading right
uh kali how can one overcome across yeah
in an aristotelian way did he say
something about it yeah he says plenty
of stuff about it and nico mccain ethics
uh book seven where there's a whole
analysis of of across yeah part of it is
like you
you uh
pick yourself up and make yourself do
the things that you need to do right or
are you like when you hear [ __ ]
arguments
being made to yourself
by yourself about why you should give in
and eat the proverbial sweet piece of
cake
you come up with a counter argument you
know there's there's all sorts of ways
of going about this
since acrasia sometimes occurs when you
get drunk or are in the throes of a
passion maybe pay attention to that sort
of thing you know
um
yonex stefan what what is one of the
main consequences of the downfall of
religion not sure what the downfall of
religion is because there seem to be a
lot of religious people and religious
institutions out here so
uh i can't really say much about that
once they named me i wasn't
do you like kierkegaard's idea of faith
that will never be able to reach
absolute objective truth after all
everything we believe will always be
subjective how much reason we employ
um so kierkegaard doesn't say that it's
we're at or unable to read absolute
objective truth you know
this cup is full that's objective that's
a truth right
there's all sorts of things where we can
reach objective truth
um the absolute there is i think
probably doing the heavy lifting and
confusion for you and not everything is
subjective if everything was subjective
we couldn't even have language because
we need to be able to
have things that are inter-subjective
right that are
um
objective to some extent um
do i like uh um
[Music]
kierkegaard's idea of faith you know
faith as a passion
faith as commitment yes i think all of
that
is is pretty awesome um
so uh
you know
that's good but i would i would try to
avoid like reading kierkegaard as being
like a complete
relativist you know
um
oops just skipped a little bit let's see
what else we've got here
a lot of good good questions in here
um
[Music]
aleonic do works of art have a duty to
attempt to convey certain social and
political messages or does doing so
diminish the aesthetic worth pleasures
of art devolving it into the didactic
again
this is the way you're framing it
you're
doing stuff at a very very high level of
abstraction
and talking about like all the works of
art
does any one single work of art have a
duty art works of art don't have a duty
artists have duties
to convey
social and political messages
no
but you know
maybe in some cases you might want to
and works of art can be looked at as
just a still life but also conveying
something about say you know
anti-consumerism
right or giving in to consumerism for
that matter
it's not as if there's like one sweeping
thing that we can say about all works of
art
and
does it diminish
the aesthetic worth or pleasures of art
depends on whose theory you ask i mean
if you talk to leo tolstoy no
depending on what the message is right
um and if you talk to
emmanuel kant maybe yes um although you
know he's got kind of a complex
and underdetermined conception of what
goes on with works of art so there isn't
there isn't like a standard answer to
that you got to kind of judge it as
you're
looking at it case by case or artist by
artist or movement by movement
luca what do you think about the concept
of genius
as it's often used by philosophers such
as schopenhauer do you think it's a
remnant of the romantic period or is
there more to it
so that's a good question
i don't think there really are geniuses
in the romantic sense uh or the
you know way in which we use that term
now there's people who are smart but a
lot of really smart people are also
pretty pretty dumb you know once they
stray out of their subject areas they
don't they don't usually have um a good
wide
range of what you know in the past we'd
call practical wisdom or phronesis
so you can be like a genius or virtuoso
at x and be completely crap in the rest
of your life in which case we'd be like
nice job genius you managed to like
alienate your wife and kids or husband
and kids or whatever and your co-workers
and you uh
because people didn't recognize your
so-called genius
um or they did and basically that meant
that they worshipped you you wound up
with a bad end right
i think
it's it's actually
it's a term that i think is done more
damage than
than good things to call people geniuses
[Music]
because it gives people like the
impression that oh i've got it all
inside of me i just have to like let it
flow out i mean there are some people
who
are very creative and very intelligent
but what you notice about them is
usually they've also put the work in
right
um so genius is not just this this thing
that you have in you and it's not just
um you know schopenhauer it's jon
stewart mill talks in terms of that in a
fairly romantic way as well
uh miroslav uh this is something i've
been asked about quite a bit before are
you going to go over some other major
work after you finish the half hour
hegel series
yeah i've already said i'm gonna you
know the next thing that i've got lined
up is descartes meditation so i'm going
to go through the
english translation and the french
translation and the original latin text
and go through it line by line
it's not definitely not as long as
hegel's phenomenology and i think i'll
probably also do anselm's prosology and
i've already done epictetus and caridian
same same uh approach right i released
all those
uh commentary videos and i'm thinking
you know what would be the next big book
probably not heidegger's being in time
uh more likely something like starts
being and nothingness um i think there'd
probably be more viewership for that
um heidegger is pretty tough too you
know
quite quite frankly
um
and then i don't know who else i would
do um i mean the half-hour hegel series
is taking me a lot longer than i thought
i'd have to figure out how i'm going to
crowdfund it too because i don't know
that everybody who wants to crowdfund
half our hegel also wants to
fund um you know sartre or somebody like
that
um
oh this is a very interesting one
from rugozilla what do you think the luz
and gatari would think of the modern
smartphone that is a great question
um i think they would have a lot to say
about
the modern smartphone i mean
to begin with so it's a piece of
technology right and it puts all this
computing power in the hands not just of
elites but of ordinary people
at the same time it also
extends um
you know the capacities for surveillance
for changing people's habits
in weird you know minor nudgy ways
it also opens up
for those who know how to use it
a vast world of literature at our
fingertips
yeah i mean i don't know that you have
to be the loser guitari to to realize
these things
um and i don't know that any like the
big big themes uh body without organs i
don't think that has anything to do with
a cell phone
um
but i'm sure they would be fascinated by
by its development
sid what's your favorite part from saint
anselm
boy that's tough
again i don't i don't have a lot of
favorites
um if i had to pick something
that i really wanted people to be clued
into
i mean it would be you know what you
find in the pro-slogan the single
argument which is not
just about god's existence but about god
being the supreme good all that all
other goods need in order to be good and
everything else that we believe about
god that's in the prologue of the pro
slogan
oh jamal asks about this book on anger
i haven't read it um it's a bunch of
essays
that were put together
um
originally there's a forum by agnes
kellard on anger
and then there's a whole bunch of forum
responses by you know various people
some of whom i follow some of whom i
don't like
i'm a fan of miesha cherry
and then there's uh
a hit a interview with judith butler
who's recently you know written stuff
about non-violence
and uh there's a piece by martha
nussbaum which you can expect because
she has a work on anger so i don't know
you know we'll find out when i'm when
i'm actually reading it
um just got it from the library recently
so
let's see
mike fuller why is your knowledge of
philosophy so limited
uh because i'm not a big brain genius
like you you know
i mean if you're gonna judge my
knowledge of philosophy as limited which
i mean everybody's knowledge of
philosophy is limited but it's being so
limited you must be like you know
you must be a a brilliant scholar who
knows an awful lot more right
lord guts how do you develop a stronger
sense of self well that's that i mean
there's no one single way to do that
right
and it depends on what you mean by a
sense of self if you mean something like
moral responsibility that's one thing if
you mean like
assertiveness and a capacity to
be able to stick up for yourself and you
know lay down boundaries and impose them
that's kind of different but they're not
totally
disconnected um
[Music]
i mean i suppose getting to know who you
are some self-knowledge would be
quite interesting or quite important
right
so
that could be
something that uh
you would need to um
cultivate and then there's all sorts of
philosophical resources
you could think about the self in
general you could think about if you're
really into like the assertiveness stuff
there's like assertiveness training that
you can do
you can think about how you can
stick up for yourself look at models you
know i think there's a lot of different
things that you could
look at
and there's there's another similar one
here
um
[Music]
how to stay motivated
you know similar sort of thing depends
on what you mean by motivation and
what's i i think with that one you can
say what is standing in your way of
being motivated what do you think
motivation
means
do you think it means like being
optimistic all the time and getting up
every morning and being like oh i can't
wait to get to work or do you think it
just means something like
being able to stick to the things that
you've decided to do when the going gets
tough those those are different kinds of
motivation right
um
xerox says one of the issues that's
holding me back from reading more is
procrastinating what tips from your
experience on the issue for me so that's
a good question
and procrastination can happen in a lot
of different ways right
one of the traps that comes up with
reading a lot
and also with writing
is
saying to yourself
i don't really have time for this now to
like give this my full attention so
therefore i must put it off to
this time and then you get to that time
and then
you don't actually do it then right
so that that's a that's a important one
and what you can do is say to yourself
something like okay so here's another
book that i've got as a prop
the cynic epistles a study edition these
aren't actually by the cynics by the way
the you know even in ancient times a lot
of people doubted whether these were
really from crates or diogenes or you
know
socrates and the socratics and stuff
like that but let's say you wanted to
read this so you're like well
i'm not going to have time to read the
whole book today
so i should put it off until next week
but then you can say to yourself you
know
i could read
the
letters of anacarsis so you're like okay
i'll i'll do that
let me go to those
and then you're you're like
uh here we go
oh man there's like
10 letters by anna karsus here
um
now it's only
10 pages
tops not even 10 pages but um
i can't do all this right now
well
you can read the first letter
and that's doing something right and
then you just build on it so a lot of a
lot of overcoming procrastination is
realizing that you are procrastinating
and then making yourself do
bits and pieces of the thing that you've
been putting off
uh for for too long
so uh let's see here
people are talking about motivation
maya mayavsky what's your opinion of
evolved uh illn cough never heard of
them
um
dc trevit do you think there's an
ancient philosopher who foretold the
infantilization of the culture i don't
think there is an infantilization of the
culture so no
um youssef speaking of tolstoy do you
have any favorite works by him i'm not
i'm not a big reader of tolstoy
sometimes i teach the death of evan
ilich
you know sometimes i teach his book what
is art in in
aesthetics classes
or in intro classes but i don't read a
lot of tolstoy frankly so
no
um
[Music]
all right
[Music]
cash money if there was one thought of
yours that you would hope or like most
to be remembered for what is
yeah i don't have an awful lot of
original thoughts
um
most of most of what i have to say it's
already been said by somebody else
so i don't i i don't know that i i have
a good question i don't know that i have
any
great responses to that i mean i've made
a few contributions in scholarship
you know
uh like an ansem scholarship i coined
the word ontological dignity but i don't
i don't
you know i hope people aren't like
that's the only thing people are
remembering me for
50 or 100 years from now
i mean i think i'd rather be known for
[Music]
having
you know produced youtube videos and
created resources for people maybe so
here's something it's this is not
original to me
but
if there was one thing that i would want
to be remembered for
claiming and arguing
it would be that
anybody who wants to can study
philosophy
it's not something that is only for
elites or smart people
um
or pick pick whatever you want
what you what you have to do is like put
in the work and find resources that help
you with
learning you know descartes or mary
wollstonecraft or simone bouvoir
and
um
develop a kind of relationship with the
author
that you're studying and you do that
with multiple authors right
and i think anybody can do that and
that's that's what i tell my students i
give them a pep talk
that
a lot of them have been told this stuff
is too too high level for you you can't
make sense of it you know
but i think that uh
that you can
do that so
[Music]
all right um greg cammer if according to
the stoics angers temporary madness how
can one not go mad with what trumpism
fascism is doing to our country and then
we have you know dk mira are you kidding
i mean mega people are fascists
i mean
i was i was reluctant to use the f word
in 2016. i think by 2017 we could say
yeah this is fascism
and it's you know fascism covers a lot
of grounds
and uh the ways in which these people
are behaving the cult light structure
the you know sheer
uh viciousness and corruption and stuff
like that that you see on the part of
republicans here
in the united states which by the way
republicans of my childhood would be
looking at and just puking you know
there is nothing conservative about
so-called conservatives anymore because
they don't look like what
genuine conservatives looked like 40
years ago they didn't conserve
conservativism instead they lurched into
fascism so that's one one question
and then you know um you could say well
if if the stoics if according to the
stoics anger is temporary madness
how do you know the stoics are right
about that
you know i mean anybody can say anything
some people say that anger is a a
wonderful
thing that we all should
cultivate and have you know
maybe the stoics are not actually right
about that
i think seneca is not the only stoic by
the way who has something to say about
anger
and epictetus does not actually agree
with seneca about whether you can reach
an angry person or not so you want to be
very careful about that kind of thing
you don't want to have anger consuming
you at all of these [ __ ] out there
on the uh
right-wing side uh lurching further and
further and further right engaging in
like outright lying and all sorts of
corruption
and violence and threatening to to riot
and stuff like that you don't want the
anger that you feel against them to
consume you and you can also realize
that these are people who are themselves
consumed for whatever reason with fear
hatred and anger
and that they have very little emotional
intelligence or control
um
seneca is right about one thing really
anything that you can do motivated by
anger
in favor of justice
you can also do motivated by practical
reason if you have a good character so
you know
that would be part of it as well
um
so andrew van orton's read the liz
brunig and nusbaum essays so that's
that's uh
that's good um
i haven't read them yet
[Music]
let's see here
zeno you mentioned how to read more you
said one should get more sleep what sort
of advice would you have to people like
me who don't get sleep and spend their
sleeping hours reading
i mean you just framed it right there
what sort of advice
maybe don't do that
right i think that's that's pretty
straightforward um
skeptical thoughts on eastern orthodoxy
i i'm not gonna really do thoughts on
blah blah blah because you gotta you
gotta specify what you what you want me
to think about
jordan says are there any thinkers who
you fell in love with whose biography
practical life made you rethink their
usefulness
um
as thinkers know um
because as thinkers the ideas
stand apart from their their own
practical life you can say they didn't
live up to
the things that they were saying right
so
um
you know you think about like paul
tillich having a massive pornography
collection right doesn't negate paul
tillich's works i mean unfortunately
paul tillich is kind of a second-rate uh
uh theologian and philosopher but the
fact that he was i mean you could say
that um
the dignity of the human person that
he's talking about is that really
compatible with this massive pornography
collection that he had been cultivating
for years and years
no and that shows that
people can be
good you know thinkers and come up with
interesting ideas and be awful uh people
as well right
um
john searle you know his his uh sort of
second rate stuff about philosophy of
language is not negated by the fact that
he was a sex pest and serial abuser and
really shouldn't have been allowed
anywhere near students
um
so i i
these don't really make that much of a
difference
muhammad says what's the most important
question in philosophy in his life
ultimately a struggle between extremes
to find some balance
what makes you feel content there's a
lot of stuff kind of thrown in there
i don't know that there's a most
important question in philosophy i'm
kind of a pluralist that i think there's
most important questions for
particular people doing philosophy that
motivate them
um
but i don't know that we have to buy
that you know like how is ah priori
synthetic uh uh you know knowledge or
propositions possible well that's a cool
thing to motivate somebody like
emmanuel kant
it doesn't move me quite so much right
so it doesn't have to be
anti gaya has some sort of ranting here
the problem is the smartphone it's
completely broken the human being's
ability for undivided attention if i'm
reading the phone stays out of the room
i mean some of us can
handle having phones and uh
not have our
undivided attention broken um i think
it's basically how you use it you know
um
mike says actually i hate motley crue
and all rock music it is fodder for low
iq people oh boy mike is really weighing
in with a lot of [ __ ] opinions here
um
give me art garfunkel i suggest you read
more and learn more gregory mike is
really kind of a prick today i guess you
know kind of a joyless prick i would say
not quite sure what he's doing here if
he uh oh
and mike says oh rock stars are morons
so mike i i wonder what the hell you
want to do here if you are such a
sour puss and you think that you know i
don't read enough and i'm not very smart
like you
um
so i think i'm gonna um
[Music]
move mike out of here
all right um
elon how can we grapple with feeling
alone and like others can't understand
us
feeling like the intellectual state of
people is too degraded and empathy only
partially
helps so i mean
the intellectual state of people is too
degraded that's that's a judgment on
your part
and i mean it might be true in the
context that you're in right maybe
you're in a
environment where you're not running
into people who
share your intellectual interests and
commitments and desires and things like
that that can be quite lonely you know
um
i remember some lonely times in college
because i went to a college where you
know it was kind of second rate and a
lot of people were only interested in
partying and i like partying but i also
wanted to discuss intellectual things
and some of the people there
who were doing that were kind of pseudo
intellectuals and some were like the
real deal
so i can kind of relate to that um
you know
fortunately you live in a time of the
internet when you can connect with
literally
thousands of people who share your
interests
and you can have online relationships
that satisfy some of the things that's
missing in your
in your face-to-face relationships you
know
um
let's see we're all we're about 10
minutes
out of the end so i'm just going to pick
a few that i can
get some
good mileage out of sid has a question
for me and my answer is not going to be
very helpful for other people how did
you get into reading or which were the
early books that made you love reading
books so i was really fortunate in that
i had
parents who took
a very
hands-on approach to my education when i
was when i was young
so my mother taught me to read when i
was three
and
we had you know like encyclopedias like
the world book and my parents were
readers and so
were a lot of other people in my family
and so there were always books around to
read and i could also like read the
newspaper or the backs of cereal boxes i
used to tick my dad off when i first
started reading because you'd be driving
in the car and i'd be reading all the
street signs to him until he told me to
knock it off
so i don't i don't really remember a
time when i wasn't reading
my wife
is even more that way she began reading
when she was 18 months old and so
you know kind of
gifted in that way and pretty fortunate
that i grew up with the
family that i did and not my birth
mother
i don't think i would have been a great
reader had i grown up with her
[Music]
so i don't know that that would be all
that helpful for everybody else
um
let's see here
just skipped a little bit
oh here's a really interesting question
by jamal
how does one stop being a
pseudo-intellectual
i feel there's a tension between that
and saying philosophy isn't an elitist
pursuit and anyone can pick books and
read
so i didn't say that philosophy isn't an
elitist pursuit i said philosophy is not
just for the elites right
and meaning that it's it's open to
anybody
uh if you put in the time if you put in
the work right
and that a lot of i can also say this
too a lot of the people that are in the
elites in terms of prestige
or
power or money are often pretty pretty
poorly informed and kind of stupid
people you know they just happen to be
lucky in the lottery of life and they
get to go to the good schools but a lot
of them kind of piss away those
opportunities
but how do you stop being a
pseudo-intellectual i mean you'd have to
figure out
what you think a pseudo-intellectual is
and then how you would surpass it and
there isn't just one
path but i mean the best way is like
being
involved with genuine intellectuals and
one way to do that is through studying
philosophy and studying other
other fields where people are making
real contributions you know if you're
living with aristotle and plato and
epictetus
a good portion of your life that's going
to rub off on you unless you're like
just learning it to like
talk about you know other
people or
or stuff like that you know
um
jack has an interesting observation to
hear about iq
demarcating music between low iq and
high iq is absolutely terrible
people who talk in terms of iq are
usually pretty stupid themselves even if
they've tested um high
in iq tests
you know it's it's smart
to actually understand the limitations
of what iq means and to claim that like
certain kinds of music are for low iq
people just shows that somebody's stupid
and probably you know filled with
resentment and hate and stuff like that
and having a pretty rough time in life
and then just sort of spewing their
[ __ ] out to the rest of us
um
[Music]
let's see
who else we've got here
um
gentry is a good question have you
thought about doing some lectures on the
philosophy of language i have um
you know i did an entire series of
lectures on aristotle's categories which
is about language language its relation
to thought and being
done some you know
lectures on heidegger that touch on that
but i haven't done like a whole sequence
on uh philosophy of language
and it'd be kind of a good thing for me
to do because that's what i was
absolutely captivated by
by the time that i was in junior year of
college
and then into i would say like my
well well past my master's
and into my phd i was like super into
languages studying them and philosophy
of language and then i kind of shifted
out of that towards towards a history of
philosophy
but i never lost my interest and love
for it so yeah that could that could be
a good idea
to to uh work on
um it's it's you know trying to find the
time to do it of course right
uh scrolling back up let's see if we've
got any other
good
things oh um
tomato and exile do you think gandhi's
non-violence and changing hearts by
making showing opponents they're wrong
still relevant work today where
attention span and listening ability is
limited so i think it has nothing to do
with attention span
or listening ability and i think that
people who talk about like today's
having less attention span um
you got to actually instead of just
assuming that or regurgitating that
that other people have said you got to
be able to demonstrate that and i mean
i've lived now 52 years
and seeing my generation criticized for
its you know lack of attention span
and then we got older and that didn't
turn out to be the case and i see the
same thing with the millennials and i
see the same thing with the zoomers so i
kind of think a lot of that like low
attention span stuff is is just what
every every generation says about other
generations it's it's not really factual
but
um non-violence
does non-violence work in all
circumstances no sometimes you actually
do have to take up arms um and you know
it doesn't we don't have to like fight
everybody all the time and you know it's
often
good to have non-violent ways to resist
evil and injustice
and that's that requires sacrifices on
your part that requires commitment you
know it's not something you can do as
just a sunday activist
um but
there's there's often evils that
just being non-violent means that you're
in some way gonna be
letting them continue doing what they're
doing
so sometimes you actually do have to you
know
fight and kill and
resist in violent ways and arm yourself
you know
the trouble is is that
a lot of the people who are using that
rhetoric now
are
actually the bad guys
so
you know
um
let's see
what else we can
answer very quickly
um
well this is this is an interesting one
uh
from joe
is it coincidental that kant never
talked about business does it have
something to do with his awareness of
the inevitable empty-handedness of the
categorical imperative when working for
money
um
kante actually does talk about business
if you read the groundwork for the
metaphysics of morals where the
categorical imperative is being
introduced
what are the examples that kant uses
a shopkeeper
who sets fair prices
that's business
so i'm not sure where you got this idea
that kant
doesn't talk about business at all i
would suggest reading kant and not
reading other people talking about khan
right
so
um
[Music]
let's see if we've got one other good
one that we can go out on oh so here's
one from cash money how do you answer
when people ask you what philosophy is
i've been studying it in university for
a while still struggle with a concise
answer
there is no agreed-upon concise answer
for what philosophy is
there are lots of definitions they don't
all agree with each other
um i wouldn't worry too much about that
and you know when people ask you what
philosophy is you say well it's a
discipline that i'm studying it's got
you know
vast literature going back 2000 so years
it exists not only here in the west but
also in the islamic world and in the
chinese cultural sphere in the indian
cultural sphere
and a lot of it consists in you know
thinking about
the things that
we experience in in the world the big
questions like what makes a person good
or bad or how should i live or you know
what is disagreement you know and how
can we overcome it or what's most real
and you know at that point their eyes
start glazing over and you're like see
there's a lot to philosophy you don't
have to define philosophy you you don't
have to be the person who's on the spot
to explain it to everybody
it's it it's fine if you
don't you know manage to do that
let's see
here's one from alexander i think the
ancient stoic stoicism has a link to
what we would call spirituality today
the keen priority and soundness of mind
and tranquility
rhymes for both
yeah stoicism does but stoicism is more
substantial than just spirituality
spirituality is one of those
loosey-goosey terms that kind of woo-woo
um it means more when you talk about
this spirituality ignatian spirituality
benedictine spirituality you know not
and not just buddhist spirituality but
pure land buddhist spirituality right
then it actually means something and you
have stoicism like platonism like
aristotelianism like even epicureanism
or skepticism these great ancient
schools or the cynics
each have their attitude towards what
makes us fundamentally human what makes
us more than just our
bodies and how we can live a good life
you know so this is a good good note to
go out on i would say um
thanks for all the questions and
comments
i got to get going because i've got a
event coming up in less than half an
hour and i got to get something to eat
before that
um but we'll you know we do these every
month and uh
hopefully i answer i didn't answer
everybody's questions but i answered
quite a few some of you are asking
questions that i've already addressed
many many times like the people asking
about g-shack
um you know i've addressed that in many
other uh amas so
if you want an answer to that you go
back to some of the earlier ones
i'll see all of you in
the ether somewhere and uh
hope you have a great uh rest of the day
here in america it's it's a labor day
weekend so we have a long weekend and uh
those of you elsewhere you have to work
on monday probably but or go to school
or whatever um hope you have a good time
there and i'll see you down the line